hallo hi schönen guten
[Musik]
tagkarte ein fertig oh me
Arsch nein ichb ich geschissen ich hoffe
richtig fett in de unter hast Hause mit
nein mir normalen Alter
diger wir wollten wir wollten a Anzüge
und nicht a
XL ich bin fresh es sind schon echt
einige da gut drauf oder was woll einmal
sagen warum da seid weil wir den Podcast
schon seit Ewigkeiten hören ich denke
beim Podcaster wir haben so verschiedene
Themen über die wir quatschen und blabla
aber le ich habe Angst die Leute zu viel
erwarten haben Erwartungen ne
keine mus ich am liebsten nach der Show
nein mach
jetzt also gerade W ich schon ich wollte
das versander nicht so sagen ich schon
her und jetzt he bitte willkommen den
ersten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
host
meinepnerin deswegen die allerbeste Frau
in ganz Deutschland die sympathischste
se Person die wir je gesehen haben
[Applaus]
mach wo
dahin
dankeil war geil
auch ich rieche jetzt nicht an dem Schuh
erster Day ist over so coolen Übergang
machen bis morgen mus ich musszen
sch guten Morgen B du da e du bist so
ein Bastard ne die erste Nachricht die
ich reinschreib von we könnt mich bitte
noch weiter schlafen lassen ich habe
fast gar nicht gepennt er kommt direkt
Kamera rein ich steck gleichas in dein
Arsch Leute wi W man auf Tour immer so
ein bisschen paar Sachen vernachlässigt
Schlaf trinken hydration habe ich für
euch beide natürlich ein Geschenk
vorbereitet und zwar die neue airup
Flasche ne euch beiden habt ihr das mal
probiert nee aber ich w schon immer
gehört ich habe euch da sogar schon so
so Pots reingemacht er funktioniert
nämlich so dass ihr einfach Wasser hier
reinfüllt da könnt ihr Leitungswasser
nehmen oder was auch immer ihr wollt
dann packt ihr den Pot oben drauf ich
habe hier zweimal Peach heute
mitgenommen und wenn ihr den eindrückt
passiert gar nichts wenn ihr den aber
rauszieht und der Port so aussieht dann
spielt er ab mit dem retronasalen
Riechen das heißt dass ihr quasi den
Geschmack über die Nase wahrnehmt weil
wir 80% generell über die Nase
wahrnehmen das checkt beispielsweise
wenn ihr irgendwie erkältet seid und ihr
wollt irgendwie was essen trinken aber
schmeckt halt nicht we eure Nase einfach
zusitzt ich fin so krass R Malin schon R
schon gut nach
[Musik]
pig krass probier mal
J das schmeckt einfach nicht mehr nach
Wasser das schmeckt wirklich nach soig
Eistee fast schon natürlich nicht nurig
sondern es gibt auch ganz crazy Sachen
es gibt Basilikum Zitrone orange es gibt
wildberry es gibt Cola also es gibt ganz
ganz crazy Dinge ich glaub gerade für
Leute das sind wirklich 90% in meinem
Freundeskreis die halt nicht gern Wasser
trinken und oft zu wenig trinken ist das
halt eine gute Alternative Sirio ganz
liebe Grüße trink ganzen Tag nur Cola
seitdem ich so eine Flasche geschenkt
hab trinkt nur noch das schei deswegen
checkt er mal ab über die Infobox da
findet ihr ein Link da findet ihr alle
weiteren Infos und wir machen jetzt
weiter unsere
[Musik]
Tour
abgucken also das wirlich nicht ich habe
mir immer schon gedacht aber habe ich
auch schon Podcast gesagt Bruder du hast
kein Nachteil
dadurch kechch wenn
andere il dadurch wenn wenn andere auch
gut sind also das habe ich nie
verstanden jetzt mlerweile kann all
sagen Kön nicht mehr aberkennen also
schön wie manche gedruckt sind hier zum
ja die Sache ist wir haben die Karten in
Köln vergessen wir haben eigentlich
schon welche prign jetzt müssen wir für
Hamburg und München noch mal hier gibt
im richtig viel Mühe die geben wir
natürlich nicht aus gen
wohl heute
zitil ich bin so nervös gerade
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was geht was geht was
gehtchine besonders gut neben dem
auspu besser vielleicht Zähne putzen
oder als mit unserem buswasser läuft
Kamera mal mein
Arsch
GuMo diger der Typ PT so ab ne das Ding
hier runtergefahren das erste Haus was
ich sehe jetzt einfach so milliardärus
mit eigener gärt wenn wir jetzt schnell
durchkommen gleich mit Essen und so
können wir vielleicht echt noch bisschen
CD würdest du dich da sehen ja
heftig ja lass mal Schnitzelessen gehen
guckt euch mal an mit was für einer
Gitarre der
spielt
ja wo ist die scheiße jetzt der
nervisschen ich habe dir gesagt l uns
den ersten Lagen gehen ich hasse
München ich will mir heute Abzeichen
holen weil hier eine Krone ist bestell
die 20 Stück Rostbratwürste der
bratwurstkönig
bratwurstkönigelsalat und
K dan das Weg kein Problem
mindset ist das wichtigste GewinnerTypen
hallo
[Musik]
München
dankeallen super wartig coolen alles
alles gut das stänchen am Ende war cool
[Musik]
ich freue mich so auf mein Bett
gerade so Freunde wir sind zurück in
Köln angekommen gerade hier noch alles
ausgeladen den ganzen Bus aufgeräumt
noch mal geschaut ob wir irgendwas
vergessen haben ja das war die Dick und
Doof Tour wir sind zwar nächste Woche
noch mal in Berlin allerdings Filmen wir
das nicht weil das coolste war diese
buour so oder so haben wir drei von vier
stops jetzt hinter uns Köln Hamburg und
München sind erledigt war sehr sehr sehr
sehr geil ich würde es aut gerade gerne
mit Sander drehen allerdings hat die
einfach ihre Sachen genommen hat sich
von ihrer Schwester aus Bielefeld hier
abholen lassen Bruder ich habe halt
heftige Schwester was soll ich sagen und
ist einfach abgecheckt ohne irgendw
tschüs zu sagen Ciao Leute diese Frau so
ein Star geworden geistkrank wir checken
jetzt auf jeden Fall rein nach Hause
gehen glaube ich alle noch mal neppen
wenn euch der Blog allerdings gefallen
hat und dieses behind the scenes mäßige
lasst ein Daumen hoch da abonniert
diesen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
aber hat eh keiner Bock drauf
[Applaus]